el legado de sigue vivo hoy se celebra
una misa en honor a la reportera
Palestina estadounidense asesinada hace
un año cuando cubría una redada del
ejército israelí en yin familiares y
amigos siguen reclamando que su muerte
no quede impune
este último año fue muy difícil para
nosotros especialmente sabiendo que no
se ha hecho justicia aún esa única bala
que la mató nos dejó con dolor y agonía
Deseando que todo fuera un mal sueño
Me siento como si fuera el primer día es
muy duro pero Seguiremos adelante porque
ese es el mensaje de shein
mujer cristiana periodista así
reivindica a shirim su sobrinalina
apoyada en testigos e investigaciones de
medios y de la ONU culpa del crimen a un
francotirador israelí Aunque Israel
admitió la responsabilidad de un soldado
como alta probabilidad se niega a
iniciar una causa judicial lo que obligó
a la familia a recurrir a la Corte Penal
Internacional
todavía estamos esperando respuesta del
fiscal con la esperanza de que tome este
caso ya que constituye un crimen de
guerra bajo la ley internacional
queremos que el soldado se haga
responsable y también la persona que le
ordenó apretar el gatillo rendir se
traduce en acciones y eso es lo que aún
no hemos visto
es lo que exige el sindicato de
periodistas palestinos
su presidente explica que shirin es una
de los 55 reporteros muertos desde el
año 2000 y denuncia que solo en 2022
hubo 902 agresiones contra la prensa
todo periodista que quiere transmitir la
verdad es objeto de ataques y crímenes
nosotros sufrimos dos veces por los
asesinatos y los crímenes y por el
silencio de la comunidad internacional
para los palestinos que le dedican
grafitis monumentos y hasta una calle en
ramala así mantienen la memoria de la
voz de Palestina